est-ce bien cet homme qui a fréquenté
une salle de sport à chalon durant
quelques mois de l'année 86 c'est dans
le cadre de la reprise de l'enquêté sur
le meurtre de sylvie aubert tués en
novembre de la même année que les
gendarmes lancent un appel à témoins cet
homme c'est ulrich muenstermann
actuellement incarcérés en allemagne
pour le meurtre d'une autre jeune fille
sylvie bâton qu'il a violé et tué à
avallon en 1989 déjà une ancienne
collègue de travail de sylvie aubert
s'est souvenu de la présence à challans
de cet homme à l'époque un souvenir que
les gendarmes souhaite conforter par
d'autres témoignages pour nous c'est une
continuité c'est à dire que l apix monde
permanent l'avait trouvé en 2007
on est revenu à plusieurs reprises c'est
donc une continuité dans les
vérifications qui sont en cours et qui
ont l'air de s'accélérer le confirmant
et tranquille à lui un parcours qu'on
peut reconstituer il a un mode
opératoire qui reconnaît fable donc
effectivement les gendarmes était de
reconstituer son parcours et de le
localiser avec certitude à ce moment-là
ou en tout cas au moment du meurtre qui
nous permettrait à ce moment là d'aller
voir plus loin de là après la résolution
des années plus tard des meurtres de
christelle blétry et christelle mairi
c'est donc à présent l'enquêté sur le
meurtre de sylvie aubert qui semble bel
et bien relancée